YOSSI FARJOUN: This is
Dr. MATLAB, lecture two,
The Command Prompt.
If you're like me,
you'll find yourself
on the command line a lot
when you're working MATLAB,
so it's important to
know how to get around
on the command prompt.
The first thing I want to show
you is how to use the arrows.
Say I want to plot something.
So I want to plot sin of 2x
between 0 and pi on 200 points.
This is what I type.
Of course, I typed
it with a typo.
I forgot to put
the multiplication
sign between the 2
and the x up here.
So we've already seen
in the previous lecture
that instead of typing
the whole thing,
I press the up command,
the up arrow, which
brings up the previous command.
And then with the left
arrow, I can place the cursor
where I need it to be
and insert the asterisk.
I forgot to put the
semi-colon, so again, I
press up at the semi-colon
and now I have what I wanted.
Now I plot x and y
and I get my plot.
I'll put it into the window.
Here it is.
Great.
Now unlike this plot, I
want to see the points,
so I'm going to press up
and modify the plot command.
And now I see the point.
And I still don't see the point
because I plotted to many.
So I, again, pressed
the up command.
I know I can press
the up command twice
to reach this line,
but what I want
to show you is what happens
when you press the up
command after I started
typing x equals.
See this x equals is the
same as this x equals here.
When I press up, the first
line that starts with x equals
will show up.
Here it is, if I
press up again, it
will be the one
without the semicolon.
If I press up again, it will be
the one without the asterisk.
Let me go back down
to the one I want.
This is the one I want.
Now I want to change this 200
to something smaller, say five.
So I could press the left area
until I reached there, and put
50 points.
And now plot again p, up, plot.
Now 50 points.
But here is a faster
way to get to that 50.
Again, x, up-- now I
want to get to the 50,
so instead of moving
with the left,
I will move with
control left, and that
moves one word at a time.
In this case, it's
not a big difference,
but sometimes it can be.
See, it skips the whole word.
It's skipping pi, it's
skipping linspace,
it's skipping the whole 50.
Let me put a 20 here.
And now I want to
plot red points.
And I have that.
Another thing you can
do on the command line
is to use Control-A. Control-A
for the beginning of the line,
to move the cursor to the
beginning of the line,
and Control-E to move the
cursor to the end of the line.
Control-A for the beginning
of the line, Control-E
for the end of the line.
You can also cut and paste.
With a shift, I select
Command-C to copy.
Let's start a new line,
Command-V to paste.
Depending on the
operating system,
those commands might
be a bit different.
Another thing you
might want to look at
is the tab completion property.
So if I start typing linspace,
I type lin s and now I hit Tab.
MATLAB will show
all the commands
it knows that start with
Lin s, in this case,
linsolve and linspace.
Of course the one
I want is linspace.
If I want to find
help on this, I
can press Control-A, move to
the beginning of the line,
add help, add help,
and then hit Enter.
Of course I can't see anything,
so I'll close this window.
And here is the
help on linspace.
And these are the two
ways you can use linspace.
You give it the lower
and the upper limit,
that gives you 100
points, equally
spaced between those two.
Or you give the
lower and upper limit
and how many points
you want, and it
get you that many points.
For example, linspace,
0 to 10, five points.
Here are five points equally
space between 0 to 10.
Another thing that the help
file shows you are related
commands that you might
want to read up on.
So I encourage you to read
up on logspace and the colon
function--
it's actually the
colon operator,
which is a very
complicated help file--
and see why linspace is
related to colon and logspace.
Another important feature
of the command line
is the use of Control-C.
So it has two main things.
For example, if you
have typed something,
let's say I've
typed this, and I've
decided I don't want
any of it, I actually
went to do something else.
So what I should do is
clear the whole line.
I don't even want
to execute this.
So to clear the whole
line without executing it,
I'm going to press Control-C.
That clears that line.
Control-C can also be used
to abort certain operations.
For example, if I say x equals
1 while 1x equals x plus 1.
So this is going to
add x all the time.
As you see, x is
going to be growing
and growing and growing
and growing forever.
Now I want to stop
this at some point.
So to stop it, really
the only thing I can do
is to press Control-C. You
see while it's running,
MATLAB says that it's busy.
Sometimes it will be busy
and you won't even see it.
Let's try that again.
X equals 1 while 1--
now I'll do it with a semicolon,
so I'll suppress output,
but it will still be doing it.
End.
So now MATLAB is busy.
It's not typing
anything on the screen,
but it's doing the
same calculation
that you saw before, except
it's not printing it out.
Again, to abort this,
we press Control-C.
You find out what x we got to.
We counted quite high.
We counted much higher
than here because we
didn't have to display.
If you're typing some other
command with a multi-line,
i equals 1 to 100, j equals
i plus 2, for example.
And midway through
that statement,
you've decided
that you don't want
to do it, again just
as before, pressing
Enter is not going to help you.
You're not going to get a
command prompt in this case.
You can end it with an end
because you started with a for,
or you could just
press Control-C.